In the last two videos we have been looking
at some of the advantages of the
fact that ‘electric current heats up objects
through which it flows’.
Electric water heaters, light bulbs and electric
iron are few of the electric
appliances that make use of this fact.
However it has its drawbacks too.
For
instance if these appliances are overheated
then they may get damaged or
even catch fire!
In fact not only these appliances, every appliance
in our house is affected by
the unwanted high electric currents.
There is a limit to the amount of electric
current that any device can withstand.
If the current exceeds that limit, the
components of the device heat up and this
may even lead to fire!
So is there
any way to prevent that from happening?
There is a device which is used to prevent
this and it is called ‘Electric fuse’.
Well it comes in many shapes and sizes.
This is what it generally looks like.
It
has a fuse wire and it is connected to the
two terminals which are made of
some metal.
This wire is made up of zinc, copper, silver
or aluminium.
The rest of the switch is basically made of
a non-combustible material.
And it
makes perfect sense too.
We should make sure that the device which
is used
to prevent fires in other devices must not
catch fire!
Now how does it prevent household electrical
appliances from catching fire?
Well this fuse is introduced in EVERY circuit
in our household.
This is how the
basic circuit will look like.
We have seen this simplified circuit in our
videos.
Ok, so when the current flows through the
circuit, it heats up the fuse wire.
And when there is heavy current in the circuit,
the wire simply melts resulting
in the broken circuit!
Yes the circuit breaks and the current does
not reach the
appliance.
So this is how an electric fuse functions!
Simple isn’t it?
Now there is one obvious disadvantage of electric
fuse that you must have
noticed!
Once the fuse wire melts, it cannot reform
itself.
We have to replace
the fuse with the new one manually!
To overcome this problem, automatic fuses
are used nowadays.
They are also
called ‘Miniature circuit breakers’ often
abbreviated as MCB.
They work like automatic switches.
Whenever there is excess amount of
current flow in the circuit, they automatically
‘switch off’.
This breaks the
circuit and the appliances are saved from
excessive current.
They also
automatically get switched on when the flow
is back to normal!